[Music]
and little [ __ ] new you little [ __ ]
submitted by Preston oh well hi that was
a teen was arrested for attempting a
wrestling move on his principal Oh which
one sleeper hold
Oh which principal assistant or vice I
thought it really matter like which kid
I don't know for some reason it said you
can't do that to an elder in charge but
what if the principal is also the
wrestling coach then yeah what part
because sometimes that principal and the
counselors are also like a sports coach
me a me okay so this 18 year old kid
named Jean that's an adult Gianni
that's a soul honey yeah he was arrested
because he was trying to do the RKO
or knock off something knock off wait so
this is like a WWE type wrestling room
yeah it's made famous by WWE's Randy
Orton oh I thought it was like a real
yeah I thought was a real wrestling move
sleeper hold was more accurate then so
if you do this like kidding around let
me show you a video
Oh
[Music]
he didn't even like get close I know
what he was trying to do try to go like
this grab him by the head and then he
and he he drops this way on his back
while he slams a guy what an idiot
though he could really hurt home I know
and he didn't even execute well no he
did it you deserve to be arrested the
principal got him Gianni I know he's
probably trying to [ __ ] around and be
funny with his friends but you don't
really hurt someone
yeah not you [ __ ] up your life you're 18
that kind looks kind of sturdy yeah okay
thick neck that's why you couldn't grab
a hold of it slipping off oh yeah
kids are dumb man oh we try to just
impress our friends like I know I would
do dumb [ __ ] just save my friend's life
and now with social media like clearly
they were filming on their phones could
you imagine having to be a [ __ ] teen
right now or the principal at a high
school right now oh god no if I was the
principal bang all cell phones with my
high school our cellphones were banned
when we were going to school but you
pulled that [ __ ] out I mean they see the
blue screen light up on your face your
house is going to in-school suspension
all I could think about is being 15
again and seeing this kind of porn today
with the fresh new eyes fresh new at 15o
cuz I grew into watching like real I
evolved with the porn you know I'm
saying like I evolved with the ages like
it we came in doses right but imagine
like being 14 15 now and having anything
at your fingertips any genre before
you're just limited to whatever your
friends passed around that's my kids are
smarter these days I think they have a
generation but Louis is like way more I
hate to say the word woke but that's
what they are generally I think people
with online like every generation now
are getting smarter because thoughts are
being more challenged and and Dumber cuz
they get into like flat earther [ __ ]
threads but you have the answer to
anything you want you don't have to go
to a library
a card and like try to like card catalog
look through an encyclopedia give a
dictionary remember that saying no one
says that [ __ ] anymore no that's so true
or you like believe [ __ ] your friends
say and then you don't know if it's
factoring go do it google it
now you just look at it yeah is this one
of those like you know how people like
they do hashtags of like dance moves and
[ __ ] and like trends was just like one
of those like trendy things where they
were like we're gonna one-up if I do in
the principal Earl like a mean thing
yeah they didn't mention anything like
RKO challenge yeah then I would be like
okay maybe a little less inclined to
blame it because he was just trying to
be cool well this kid is just like
obsessed with rustling Oh
he ended up wrestling an alligator with
your people did you wrestle well in
elementary school instead of like
tornado drills we were taught alligator
drills what two alligators drill so like
important you know what portable is like
a bungalow Feeny yeah like so are all of
our schools are outdoors because the
weather's so nice there's no like indoor
school yes like here sometimes you would
have portables where it would be in
really tall grass like outside and when
you haven't really told grass yeah like
there would be alligators and [ __ ] and
so they would teach you how to run in a
zigzag pattern and they would make you
learn how to run zigzag and you do it
like in between cones as it confuses
them or something yeah cuz alligators
can't run the exact thing around
straight really [ __ ] fast if you run
straight from alligator your ass is
grass so they get tired cuz you're going
to gonna ask for something about their
like body movement where they can't go
like so you just check out now oh my god
he just probably saved my life yeah
that's true it's probably hard for them
to turn this way those are the little
arms
like you know that's why people grab
them by their tails oh yeah Oh cuz they
turn around okay
I go to different parts she travels yeah
I got a passport but I don't know what
to do in a tornado situation no you
should quick drills here yeah and like I
don't know any uh [ __ ] so like
alligators don't faze me like I would
walk up to one and write you know you're
supposed to get a bathtub I heard Casey
told me cuz he grew up in Dallas my
husband he said that you get into a bed
supposed to be the safest place fly over
like you're its protect it's almost a
roll what if your bathtubs on the second
floor probably first floor bath maybe
even though the same thing is getting a
doorway that's really well the old thing
I heard that that was in the what's a
new thing now I'm gonna die
Dorothy goes to the basement or she
tried to remember that movie about that
tornado [ __ ] the tornado chasers yeah
scaring the cow it goes like an
alligator let's make a more famous that
boy got had to move everything he's 18
hmm it's a fake Ellie
but he loves wrestling don't look at all
those moves he loves it he would be a
great YouTube sensation I can't say [ __ ]
cuz that was me and that wasn't that was
us in our 20s - I choose this do -
around in a Superman outfit and he
jumped inside of a fountain and swam
away from me that's true yeah he damaged
the alligator which is valued at 3,600
in battleship so I was like a plastic
alligator he did this on a local mall so
kids teens in malls bad combination
that's the only thing teens got nothing
good happens at a mall with the team I
know they're saying that this alligator
wrestling thing happened before the
principal one so he was trying to do
that move on the principal maybe he's
trying to be a wrestler and in Florida
honestly that's where it's hot tampa
orlando WWE maybe he's got a future
ahead of him
that's what we should do we should do it
you and spin this into a positive
let's get that kid in a program like
that annoying you seven build a straight
program where a lot of problems happen
because they don't got [ __ ] to do I know
I was one of them yeah yeah
they need stuff to do mm-hmm or they do
drugs yep I did both mm-hmm yep I did
all of that [ __ ] that's whatever in
Santa Barbara like all the problems
Santa Barbara yeah that's what I'm
saying but one thinks that but it's like
not that bougie like everyone's like an
artist instead they're like Beach
hippies and stuff but then there's
Montecito where's all the rich kids and
they're all like depressed and coked out
because there's nothing to do and
they're all like too rich I hate it when
I'm tired yeah there's one girl she
would do meth and then she would like
drive her [ __ ] parents car into a
wall because she said she want to be a
NASCAR driver
what and then her parents were like yeah
you fulfill your dreams and then she
would you [ __ ] bunch of speed only
they knew about that part and then she
she'd rammed their car into a wall and
she's like yeah it's practice for my
NASCAR career and they
our new car what that's real love yeah
that was separate from like the majority
of the Santa Barbara this case just use
born that seems like she got behavioral
issue yeah but everyone got really bored
and did and did meth I didn't do it but
my for a lot of my friends did and got
sent to rehab oh really
it'd be cool if like the wrestling coach
scouted him watches these videos and
like come on join the team I'll teach
you some stuff yeah he's passionate
about it yeah clearly he's good at it I
think based on that alligator video yeah
good have a bright future yeah that
alligator didn't stand a chance he
[ __ ] that alligator oh it was good I
want to see him try to do this with the
real application oh [ __ ] you know just
trying to chill out of it oh that's kind
of [ __ ] up too Oh was he also
principal as cool or were they like I
never met my prince I never met mine
either
vice principal I guess the principal was
cool the vice principal was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
she um took away my like I had jewelry
on that was like from Claire's but it
was spikes jewelry like spikes but it
wasn't even like you go like this enough
nothing I remember that Fashion Show
take those over like she would take them
away and then she said that she wasn't
gonna give it back and I'm like that
stealing in elementary school no this
was in high school oh yeah and she gave
me in-school suspension because I had my
shirt tied up like because I was the
style at attendant or not and the
cheerleaders are walking around like
spaghetti straps and like little tiny
shorts but because my shirt was like
this and I was like punk rocker person
um okay yeah she was like you take your
shirt down and so I did and then when
she was gone I put it back up and then
she caught me and she gave me a
in-school suspension and I cried like a
little [ __ ] because I was missing a
history test and I thought I was gonna
fall behind in the class you weren't
allowed to wear sandals in high school
we weren't either
why though that's weird I don't know
okay fire hazard wait where that wasn't
in a beach town yeah Florida that's
weird
no driver Jenks no what is that grace
wait a lot oh that's it that's a problem
yeah it's probably it's a problem oh
that one's ever so slimy she would like
give me you give me a receipt and then
when I pull it out of this Hannah just
smudge there dad we just melted the
whole thing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]